this is my dick yours looks like this  you're saying now it does yeah but  before that was a little chubbier yeah  yeah it looked like a nub  it is true it shrinks right you don't  even understand when you get fat your  stomach gets big but you you have a dick  stomach yeah like I didn't know there  was a big stomach yep until all of a  sudden I was yeah I used to jerk off  with one hand then I started jerking off  with just two fingers you were just  losing digits you're like King viserys  you did get smaller yeah when the fatter  you get it goes away and when you lose  weight that's a full fist I'm back I'm  about to one and I can do this  I lost weight like Chase said the other  night I was like yeah they look great I  was like thanks I lost the weight he was  like whoa whoa not the weight you lost  some weight